hey reject nation its Greg Alba here
John Humphrey we are going to watch a
patron video request one of our reward
tiers whatever video you request we must
definitely cover 90 it's usually a
reaction I can only think of a couple
times where wasn't anyway today comes
from Lance door
this is Avengers infinity war ten years
in the making tribute by mr. Krupp shish
who has an amazing YouTube channel
amazing channel you guys check out more
of his videos by the way and Lance door
is a guy who lives in Canada just like
the Ryan Reynolds and the Ryan Gosling
and he is a very kind hearted human
being one of our top pledge is currently
on patreon last time I talked to this
guy I got to know a little bit more
about him he has a son named manna which
means man of respect and he has a
girlfriend named Nick got ID [ __ ] D got
ID and I got and I got T got [ __ ] [ __ ]
ty which means constantly cheats on
firefighters oh but Lance is a
firefighter wow that's that's Lance
oh boy Lance you better look out man you
better not get married to your
girlfriend or else let's just say you're
gonna have to put out a lot more fires
if that happens she's kind of a cheat up
in a baby
I wonder if cheating is more pleasant in
Canada probably they probably handled it
very civil I'm just joking I'm sure
she's very faithful and is very sexually
active I hope you're doing a good job
anyway guys let's watch this
[Music]
at all once said that's in America so we
create demons who said that
what does that even mean doesn't matter
I said it cuz he said so now he was
famous and basically getting sent back
to Bowman guys I don't know let's track
this from the beginning
damn your life could enjoy some dialogue
there buddy vines feels up or are you
going to do something John into anything
the kids and you
Vidar Bobby doesn't wait this is a very
important week we visited we should be
watching my super easy I just finally
know when I have to do the sacrifice
yourself for the aging technology i in
Thor the God of hammers yep that hammer
to help you control you to focus
it's now being a source of strength it's
to exploded taking out god it's so much
more there's not a place
two people struggling to you know it's
daunting
daddy Wow
you got about that shot that's right you
not a threat to me
this kids good editing yeah right in the
right we have a graduation ceremony
sterilized you
Jennifer Lawrence
[Music]
me strangers easier even Kili
doesn't matter what you did or do you
were
you step out the door you're an Avenger
we're Avengers
just like that Hawk I recruited you when
you can do the things that I can
but you don't
and then about these happen
[Music]
they happen to be
[Music]
the thing you're searching has dad's
dogs Rittenhouse I know you will always
be my sister don't even know it
never see us daddy issues
[Music]
oh good time starlet Praslin know what
it's like to lose feel suggestively
which you're right always fail
all the same
of quota B if that was an Avengers for
ya
there was an idea god remember what Nick
Fisher a group of remarkable people
this is we could become
something
these guys are always posing so we could
find the bottles that was a funny scene
[Music]
my nipples are really hard crap [ __ ] man
way to go Krishna ruptures prettier
ruptures you know if an infinity war
hadn't come out I know this video is
those Avengers infinity war ten years in
the making
people have made making super cuts with
the Marvel movies since like phase one
they usually make a variety of epic
emotional way or a bunch of cool battle
action sequences and there's a couple of
things that I really love about this
specific compilation one is it's very
brief for ten years and it officially
captures that and the other side is it
communicates the weight the heaviness
the thickness the sacrifice the journeys
they've all had to go on and sometimes
when I would see these compilations
prior to watching infinity war I would
always be like well these movies are a
lot more humorous and I never really
feel this sense of devastation that
these super guns are trying to
communicate yeah but this one because of
how infinity war really lives up to the
epicness the weight and that level of
devastation exactly that loss yeah this
super cut it was really applicable in
terms of that if any war had to come out
this is another one of those regrets I'd
like what these guys always win you know
yeah I most definitely and I gotta give
props to zan mr. Crouch's here for just
choosing so many great moments for this
because it really does feel smooth and
unified this could have been something
Marvel themselves put out if they wanted
yeah I know and to go with that choice
of having the narration over the
different clips and stuff I thought I
chose great themes you know in the
narrations to pick out stuff I haven't
seen a million of these super cuts but
this one definitely got that sense of
gravitas that that stuff that you care
about you know yeah for me it was cool
that he chose emotional moments they're
spliced together nice it was like the
beginning of a lot of their journeys on
every one of them but the beginning of a
lot of their journeys as them as
individuals and then some of the family
themes in it of sacrifice you know when
he's cutting around from like star-lord
crying Gamora and nebula hugging each
other
Rocket Raccoon and Groot saying bye to
each other it does this good job of
knowing what emotional moments to pack
together as opposed to just taking a
bunch of cool battle sequences and
showing that because you know the Marvel
films are a lot of humor ass plays ass
burg cos god majority of them feel a lot
lighter in tone than this super cut but
in terms of linking it to leading up to
infinity war this is perfect and in fact
I affinity of war lives up to it - yeah
I mean it highlights everything that led
to infinity war while also highlighting
the character stakes
yeah because even in just little moments
but like what each person is dealing
with like Natasha and Bruce talking
about we can't do the like I will never
have a real family but we can identify
based off that or Peters saying if you
can do what I do and you don't it's your
fault just those little things or Thor
you know Odin telling him like you were
more powerful than me just those little
personal notes it's not like what you
mainly associate with the MCU but it
made me really appreciate them through
this video oh yeah these are always the
the heavier themes at hand and where
there's a script though that's a lot
lighter
yeah jump back and forth a proportionate
amount between the different characters
cuz right about the time I started to
wonder what's the shape of the supercut
gonna be then Captain America shows up
and you revisit him for a little bit and
then Thor and so on this was beautifully
done man this is beautifully done shouts
out to yinsen miss that guy yeah
everybody talked about since that one
movie and he was such an integral part
of Iron Man's journey he's arguably
responsible VMC's you're not to bring
back yinsen
yinsen Cinematic Universe I'm feeling it
yeah man him in that Sun that that died
he's in franchise guys you can subscribe
to the reject nation click that
notification about the subscribe buttons
are broken mr. crap just follow this
mofo as soon as you can and on patreon
we got full-length TV show reactions we
got weekly Q&A s we got music video
coverage and a bunch of other goodies
would love to have you become a patron
eject
day